the cell phone has the mortar for
african-american did any legislation or
any bill that could have ever been
passed because now for the rest of the
world we're not just complaining we've
got evidence we've got footage of how
we're living every single day we're not
just taken for our word we have to
literally say we have this on video do
you believe us now
George Floyd a 46 year old black man was
killed on May 25th after Minneapolis
police officers arrested him for
allegedly trying to pass off a
counterfeit $20 bill video that emerged
showed a white police officer derrick
shavon pressing his knee on Floyd's neck
for nearly nine minutes as Floyd was
handcuffed and to the ground and
repeated that he couldn't breathe the
killing of Floyd in police custody
sparked nationwide protests fueled by
calls to end the police brutality and
systemic racism The Wall Street Journal
assembled a group of professionals from
around the country a psychiatry resident
a Ferguson Missouri restaurant owner a
school principal an entrepreneur and a
diversity and inclusion manager who is
also the niece of Christian Cooper
Central Park bird watcher who asked a
white woman to leash her dog only to
have her call 9-1-1 to say an
african-american man was threatening her
we sat down with the group virtually to
discuss the continued challenges they
face and their personal and professional
lives as black Americans and the changes
they want to see in this country in one
word can you describe what these past
two weeks have been like for you
personally there have to be overwhelming
I've been in this situation before with
the rioting with the Mike Brown with my
restaurant being a few doors down from
the Ferguson Police Department but I was
totally taken by surprise this time I
had a heads up when it was 2014 that
this could possibly happen and I was at
work the day that the rioting and
looting happened this time and I left
work about 6:00 p.m. I weighed to the
protesters it was definitely 100%
peaceful I was totally support you know
and had no idea that it was going to go
from one extreme to the other I would
say tiring I feel like it's been two
weeks since that came
before that there was Brianna Taylor
there's a mod armory there was the whole
thing that happened with mr. Cooper in
New York City like this has been an
ongoing thing I feel like what happened
with George Floyd was kind of the the
climax I bet that entire rise of just
like black massacre I lack of a better
word Dylan what do you think I would say
training a lot of people reaching out
asking questions about what they can and
should be doing and this tug and pull
between wanting to be there and respond
as well as recognizing that there's
probably a greater necessity for
self-care now more than other in our
community and when you take all of those
things in one and there's the competing
interest or which one do you address
first it takes on Regina 7 training I
struggle with that one word cuz I feel
like my emotions really just go up and
down arm so I would say more like
ever-changing I think I'd go from this
place of frustration to this place of
like like just exhaustion I'm in Houston
Texas and so we had about 60,000 people
show up downtown and I was down there
and you know I was able to see just the
magnitude and the beauty of the people
just coming together to rally around
this 2020 has now been playing games
with place we've all gotten this a lot
how are you questions
how have you been answering it and does
your answer differ depending on the race
of the person you're talking to I know
people have been asking me on a personal
level how I am after viewing the video
in Central Park with Amy Cooper and my
uncle Chris Cooper
it's definitely taken a toll on me
personally on our family the incident
with my uncle Chris happened in the
morning and George Floyd was killed
that evening within 24 hours and he had
two national examples of what's going on
you're probably about 3 or 4 days after
the incident with George Floyd where you
know there was like this sense of you
know the white world was just going on
I probably talked to about six different
black males that day and everybody had
the same frustration in their life why
hasn't anybody said anything you know
and then it almost seemed like something
like switch and then saying something
became the thing to do one thing like so
thank you for acknowledging this is my
everyday life and this is how you know
we live and how we you know how to
adjust to America but then to um you
know we need you to speak up on a
regular basis we need you to be
addressing this all the time I think
that particularly for the black
professional who in many spaces is the
only black face it just adds this
additional burden of being an educator
when I'm talking to a white person I
don't know that I can always be as
honest or share my frustration
particularly a professional environment
I don't want that to impact my work life
I don't want that to you know we can't
always trust that that's gonna be a safe
space a lot of the agendas and
suggestions and and different statements
that a lot of companies and corporations
are making and a lot of their diversity
measures that they're now undertaking
these are things us and the DNI space
have been saying forever and it's kind
of interesting that it took a massive
shake of the world to really get people
to pay attention at the same time I
think that really mirrors the black
experience in this country we have been
saying for 400 years this is happening
to us this is bad this is what we're
experiencing as you were working your
way up professionally did you ever feel
like you weren't able to to be yourself
in your professional environment did you
feel that you needed to basically keep
some of yourself hidden from colleagues
in order to to better appeal to them
jadon let me start with you I think that
being a black woman being a young black
woman looking even younger than I
actually am I am definitely aware of how
I'm received in corporate spaces I think
that what works against me
more than racial biases its perceived
age bias another thing that I have
challenges with are kind of
stereotypical ideas about black people I
am very careful with my emails with my
tone with the way I speak my inflection
the look on my face even it's very
difficult to constantly look at yourself
in the mirror while trying to live
sometimes I might have a short response
or not respond as well as I should but I
know that if that happens I'll be angry
forever help you categorize as difficult
to deal with jami'a so you've none of
your hello out there oh yeah I mean I
think that ultimately the way that I
show up in work I have to you know I got
a bad a thousand every time there are
days where I leave the work leave work
and I have to literally call a black
person my parents my sister my friends
and we literally talk about all the
white stuff that happened to us
throughout the day all the things people
said to us all the frustrations that we
had that we couldn't share or we
couldn't say in a way that we wanted to
or how we had to how we had to restrain
ourselves when somebody put their hands
in here and wanted to know why it looked
like that you almost have to be a
completely different person my work self
you're not talking to the real Jamie
downs you're talking to the work Jamie
does and he has to you know be
articulate he has to be prepared he has
to you know make sure that you know
everything is together because people
are watching and you know and and that's
the only way to get noticed because if
your mediocre you won't stand down but
the way to to to promotion is the way to
leadership is you have to be excellent
all the time it's an interesting
thinking about the stereotype of the
wall streeter even now and back when I
started on the trading floor and it
really hasn't changed like there's a
typical person that you think of and
it's probably not a 5-7 Nigerian woman
so I just remember starting and looking
out into this this sea of hundreds of
people and if you remove the
administrative assistant
seeing only a handful of people that
really looked like me so if I were
thinking back to like how I approached
my career it was very much so that it
wasn't just thinking oh that's the
Nigerian girl on on the trading floor or
the black girl on the trading floor
that's like oh that's the girl that
actually knows algorithms really well or
that's the girl that is excellent
financial literacy and she made a great
video that's on our global platform or
that's the woman that spoke at the CEOs
off-site and having my authentic self be
that you view me as someone who is
excellent not just notice the fact that
I stand out because of my skin's skin
color but you notice that I am somebody
that performs what can businesses do to
help change things it's been great to
have see these letters from a CEO it's
been great to see people's social media
messages but what's the next step
companies need to first look internally
and examine their own corporate policies
and ensure that their values reflect
what they're saying to their employees
and that has buy-in from the bottom up
as well as the top down and then
consumers can also hold their companies
to task by saying if you're not
reflective and you're not following
through our business very well can go to
the multitude of competitors I do and a
lot of times people look at the riots
and everything that is happening and
they're trying to say how could they
destroy their own community and the
truth is we don't own our community but
if we are given the opportunity to buy
those buildings or even hope that they
want the help that put ownership in the
black community I'll promise you when
you own something you take a different
pride in it
I saw these big companies like Netflix
and Hulu and Amazon standing behind
black lives matter and I can remember
when they were looking at lives matter
my visit errors can you remember that in
2014
now the tone is totally changed with all
this footage of african-americans being
killed at the hands of officers
innocently allow us to own what's in our
community allow us to be grocery store
holders but we're going to need their
help we're going to need their funds
we're going to need their training their
information it is a lot of things that
we don't know because we haven't grown
up like them in America that it's been
passed down from generation to
generation to generation
if they really want to make a change and
do something different invest in us to
chef Kathy's point when I shared my
story about my uncle on LinkedIn
I definitely hesitated LinkedIn is a
professional networking space I was
cautious about sharing a personal story
and I was cautious about sharing the
story that could be polarizing and when
I was writing my post in deciding what
hashtags to use I did not use the
blacklivesmatter hashtag um I know it
can be divisive I wasn't courageous
enough to put blacklivesmatter on a post
now not even a week later we're seeing
major companies in corporations
parting their lips or writing on paper
black lives matter I think that things
have significantly changed and companies
are paying attention I think they are
starting to make an effort to put their
money where their mouths are supporting
different causes I support civil rights
and in social justice I think they're
taking a good hard look at their own
internal practices in terms of diversity
and advancement in occlusion because
again no one wants to be the next
headline no one wants to be the next
hashtag no one wants to fumble this
opportunity just give us a specific
conversation that you had with somebody
could be a colleague a parent child just
during this whole time that that really
impacted you yeah I would say was with
my wife you know black women also from
Kansas City we drive you know to the
Midwest all the time and like you know
we had to come together at some point
during this time and like literally
discuss like a safety plan like what are
we gonna do if we're pulled over like
who has the cou as a camera who's who do
you know who is it that is going to talk
to the officer or something goes left
like what is it that we're going to do
and then having the fog the further more
conversation of man how much does it
that we have to literally come up with a
plan on driving to go see our my in-laws
they're her parents the first person
that popped to mind is is the
conversations that I've been having with
my sister and it's been because of this
backdrop of code
for contact she's an epidemiologist but
also someone who's like very passionate
and fierce and typically wants to be out
there protesting and she's actually been
attending the protest in her car we have
these events and it's like well how do
you win because if it's not a pandemic
it's it's you know some kind of other
brutality and like how do you make an
impact is it stay home or go out we're
like a tag-team duo about like what are
the things that we can do that we can
keep pushed for dating cuz she bored on
multiple fronts
so I'll think about a conversation I had
at the protest I saw a bunch of my
students their kid looks at me he's like
you know mr. downs I just I don't know
what it is I just say every time I walk
past an officer my heart starts beating
fast and I'm I'm you man you know like
we're good we're out here we're doing
out here so I know but you know what's
stopping them from you know doing it the
tear gas or you know setting us up or
you know provoking us from doing
whatever you know like it's just crazy
out here you know and so I think when I
think about that right this is a young
man who is trying to do the right thing
he's trying to exercise his right as an
American citizen and yet and still he's
surrounded by 60,000 people that are
aligned with him that are rooting for
the cause that he's rooting for he's not
doing anything wrong and he still
surrounded by to me I see a bunch of
black people he's still aware that he's
a young black man in America he's still
aware that you know he could potentially
be in danger because this society's not
for him I just think about the work that
we have to do to make our kids feel safe
to make them feel like they belong to
make them feel like they truly have a
part of this country and even in that
powerful moment this young black man is
still afraid for his life he's still
afraid that um something could happen
and that's that's not okay
Kathy what specific conversations have
you had with your son about not just
this incident but just about racism in
general we talked to my son every day
about being a black man and being out we
tell them on plays music too loud when
he's in his car driving he's gonna make
sure his driver's license
is accessible that he does not have to
reach for it he doesn't have to open
anything so they can't say he's reaching
for a weapon or a gun or a knife do you
ever get stopped by the police you make
sure both of your hands are on the
steering wheel and then you ask the
author so what are you being stopped for
and you just put both hands up exactly
like this and you reach like this for
your license to grab it because you have
it accessible you don't have to go
inside to get it and the great thing is
because they are so where because of
social media it's not a fight
they want to live just as much as you
want them to live how have you been
talking to kids about all this Jamie you
work in a school I'll start with you I
had to really decide what I was going to
say what I found to be true is the more
that I elevate my voice and I empower my
students to elevate their voice the more
the better response we give we have to
do better in terms of the opportunities
that we provide and I'm saying that as a
black school leader you know that it's
there's more that we have to do in that
we can't continue the status quo because
we're in many ways perpetuating this
cycle that's leading to the pre arm the
school to Prison Pipeline that's leading
to our students not having you know the
best relationship or being ever have
opportunities outside of the school you
know we have an election coming up
I need these students to understand that
yes we're going to protest yes we're
going to advocate for change but one of
the biggest ways you do that is by you
know going to the booth and voting it
starts with how you talk to children
about what they can do what does it say
to tell someone at the age of 10 yeah
you could be a private equity investor
or you should be somebody to actually
consider running for election or you
should be the voice have changed I work
in a school that's in a very in a
low-income area in Houston so when
you're talking about you know not only
do we need people that to get in front
of students to tell them guess you can
be an investment banker yeah you can't
you know be a politician you can do
these things but they need to also be
people that look like them they need to
get back they need to be a bridge
builder we have to take you know more
ownership in terms of making sure that
we're doing things that are connecting
to students to opportunities
and to people who look like this the
thing that I think about our pipeline
programs like especially with them
getting people into the sciences and
within medicine has been one of the
things that which I like we've been
trying to get back to because of the
fact that like seeing a black doctor or
a black lawyer or something else like
that is so unheard of when I walk into a
room with the patient who's who looks
like me
you know they're practically relieved
like oh thank God like you know I can
actually talk about like what's going on
and not feel as though I'm being judged
off of like you know oh well do you have
do you have diabetes you have
hypertension and like I haven't even I
was coming in for a cold why are you
asking me all these questions my son's
graduation was Sunday the day after
their rights and at that graduation I
would I don't think I've ever been to a
graduation that was so cheerful those
kids that just come out of those riots
that night and they had to you know
graduate walk across that stage and they
all have a mask everyone on the stage
has on masks and if you could have heard
the speeches that these children were
giving they were heart-wrenching what
I've realized for my own children being
at home going through this
they're watching more news not the way
that we used to because they're younger
of course all social media but the
conversation is constant about what's
happening and not just looking at
clothes and how to do your eyebrows and
all this anymore
they're so focused on what it's
happening in the world my husband and I
we were talking about Colin Kaepernick
you know he had the most stuff by the
way yeah yeah yeah he's taking a knee he
did the most silent protest that anyone
could ever ever do and he had all the
worst things in the world happened to
him and all that Mandy it was taken knee
and so you got the young people that are
watching him you know and they feel like
this happened him this silent protest
and this man lost everything he had so I
think this new generation is gonna find
a way and what I love about it these
demonstrations have been white and black
together this is their generation and I
believe they are going to make a change
they're gonna force a change to happen
Torelli you were talking about how
racism is a public health crisis explain
that there's a robust amount of
literature that looks at the effects of
like stress and trauma on the body I
think one of the things that we don't
necessarily talk about is how African
Americans for example and others have to
deal with the stress of walking around a
racialized environment how many of us
have gone through our education and
educational programs having to be
singled out because of because of their
color I remember in eighth grade I was
literally sold as a slave as it means of
teaching everyone else in that play in
that class about what well slavery was
and like you know that was traumatic to
me or like in how many of us like as
we're driving our car around our heart
beats our heart rate increases when a
cop is behind us these are trauma is
that like we may pass on to our children
you know genetically not even hunts them
you know not not even how we socialize
our kids but just basically how we
internalize and carry our trauma this is
like a Russian nesting doll of like the
various different times the various
different ways of which that we
experience like you know racism whether
it's individual whether it's systemic
whether it's institutional you know and
and all of those things all come
together as a means of you know being
very challenging for black people to
kind of ascending to generate wealth and
to you you know self-determined for the
most part and do that without having to
feel as though in some way they're being
held back I just can't help but wonder
like the the trauma of kind of doing the
black math that people have to do
intraday which is you know if I wear
this then will I be okay or you know
this person like used a racial slur
towards me and what is it statistically
safe for me to engage or not or if I get
stopped by somebody and if I do these
actions put my hands we're supposed to
and wait to ask if it's okay to reach
for something will I be okay and I have
an older brother who's autistic so when
these events happen the first thing that
I start thinking about is him and the
fact that one he's existing while being
a black man period
secondly goodness forbid somebody
misinterprets his disability besides
just being a black man as a cause for
danger and like I can totally admit that
there's times that I have been like
totally paralyzed like called my parents
like make sure that he knows what to do
in all these scenarios but he's been
quizzed that he knows the quote/unquote
right equation of things to do that will
hopefully keep him as safe as possible
so raise your hand if you think this
time is different that there will be
meaningful change can I stick in halfway
up yeah I explained here here and here
that's the problem though I think that
because we're so hesitant right because
and it's also because we don't want to
disappoint ourselves right we're trying
to protect like our hope in the world in
this country right I was also hopeful
that that election wasn't true but it
was I can no longer be like you know
what I'm too frustrated to have this
conversation and so I think that I have
to be hopeful that is going to change
but I'm also going to give my all to
making sure that it changes
I think our leaders fail to act because
we don't like do everything in our power
to hold them accountable I'm a mother to
a preteen I know as black and brown
people we've been talking to our
children about their place in the world
since they've been born since they've
been able to talk I know that there are
certain conversations that parents of
black boys have that are very difficult
conversations my daughter has been out
of school since mid-march because of
kovat normally my daughter would know
what was going on kind of in the news
and in the world because they would
discuss it in their classrooms our
students are missing these educational
opportunities and are relying on us as
parents or as caregivers to let them
know what's going on in the world to
have these conversations and heighten
their awareness and I think the
teenagers the the students that are in
college right now that people that are
coming behind us I see a lot of passion
I see a lot of hunger and I see though a
desire for better
strange positive externality of kovat is
the fact that there's a lot more people
online scrolling consuming the news to
be awoken to what's happening and what's
been happening and you know this crave
for education is curry for consumption
has made it so that way it's a lot more
people than just just Black Voices also
wanting to push for something more the
reason why it's half way is because it
doesn't just stop with a week it
actually is that accountability factor
that says we're not stopping tomorrow
we're gonna stop something next week
we're thinking about both the short term
and the long term impact that it's going
to take and expecting accountability
along the way I think that the dynamic
that I'll be remiss that we didn't
address though is ultimately we all went
to college we all have opportunities we
all are connected to networks that we
are going to drive on because of our
privilege and our experiences that have
allowed us to do that there are tons of
black kids that go to schools that live
in communities that are underfunded
under resource and so as a society we
have to stop press pause and take a hard
look if we truly want the United States
to be a country that is equal
opportunity for all then we gotta
provide equal access people are saying
what do you want from these companies
what do you want from these leaders tell
them we have an opportunity now where we
can put on the table what it is we're
asking for from my own experience with
myself and with my children it is
enormous students they get that money or
the cream on the top of the screen
students they're the kids that's already
doing the things that they should be
doing
they are the kids that show up for
everything they these are the kids
we're probably gonna make it regardless
without all the other stuff because of
the parenting behind them that I think
in the system it has to be a change how
do we how do we change the life of a
Sisu it I agree but at the same time
also the people who are at the cream of
the crop are there despite substantial
challenges I agree that there are a lot
of different opportunities for
businesses to come in and other places
to like try to generate wealth within
the black community but I also think
that there's a huge barrier there in
regards to how black children black
black adolescents black adults are
treated as though they're second-class
citizens or at the very least as though
that like you know you have to you have
to damn now prove your exception the
part that requires more work is trying
to tease out this aspect of like when I
see a young black male with a hoodie on
why am i afraid seeing them come down
the street why do I think that this
person is going to hurt me if I see a
kid that's struggling with a see how do
I instead of saying you know what this
is this is all that this kid couldn't do
how can I encourage this young black kid
to do better and so like when it comes
to like white people asking what I can
do and what I can do to help it's like I
you know I what I need you to address
these underlying biases that you have I
need you to come at it from a place of
like how can i elevate you
[Music]